En 1980, al histórico líder del Cártel
de Medellín, Pablo Escobar Gaviria se le
encendió la bombilla.
Por así decirlo, tuvo una visión, un sueño:
convertir a Colombia en un narcoestado; un
país donde el propio gobierno y las propias
instituciones públicas estuvieran dirigidas
y controladas directamente por el narcotráfico.
Tal fue su empeño, que en 1982 - como
creo que todos sabéis - él mismo, el propio
Pablo Escobar, uno de los mafiosos más importantes
de toda la historia, terminó sentándose
en la cámara de representantes de la República
de Colombia.
Y… amigos… no perdamos de vista una cuestión…
Una cosa es que la mafia compre, soborne a
un político y otra muy distinta que ellos
mismos controlen el poder.
¿Os imagináis un país donde la policía,
el ejército, los funcionarios de la administración
y hasta los propios tribunales estuvieran
en última instancia bajo las órdenes directas
de los narcos?
Desde luego, amigos, de haberse llevado a
cabo la visión de Pablo Escobar, Colombia
no solo habría multiplicado sus niveles de
producción y exportación de narcóticos,
sino que el propio Cartel de Medellín hubiera
sido intocable, invencible….
Hubiera logrado la total impunidad para hacer
y deshacer a su antojo.
Por fortuna, Pablo Escobar Gaviria nunca consiguió
llevar a cabo su sueño…
Sin embargo 3 décadas después parece que
su sueño, ahora sí, se está llevando a
cabo; claro que… en esta ocasión no hablamos
de Colombia sino
de Venezuela.
Según parece estos cuatro personajes que
estáis viendo…. No solo tienen el control
del país, sino que además son los líderes
de toda una red internacional del crimen y
el narcotráfico.
Hablamos, por supuesto, de Nicolás Maduro,
Presidente de Venezuela.
Del poderoso presidente de la Asamblea Nacional
Constituyente, Diosdado Cabello, al que muchos
ya sitúan como el hombre más fuerte del
régimen.
De Tareck El Aissami, exvicepresidente y actual
ministro de Industria y Producción Nacional,
cuya fortuna personal, según los cálculos
de la DEA supera, ojo, los 3.000 millones
de dólares. ¡3000 millones de dólares!
Y, el cuarto, Néstor Reverol, ministro de
relaciones interiores, justicia y paz, que para
colmo, fue el anterior Director de la Oficina
Nacional Antinarcóticos.
Pues bien, todo apunta a que estas cuatro
personas están liderando la transformación
de Venezuela en todo un narcoestado. Atentos
(LA MAFIA TOMA EL CONTROL)
Venezuela está en la ruina. El hambre está
creciendo, la inflación está descontrolada,
cientos de miles de personas están huyendo.
Ya ni siquiera los hospitales tienen suministros
básicos como medicinas, equipos de análisis
o tiritas.
Amigos, el desastre es tan grande que la propia
PDVSA; la empresa nacional de petróleo del
país con más reservas del mundo, está en
quiebra.
Fijaos…
A día de hoy, PDVSA tiene tantas órdenes
de embargo que para poder vender el cada vez
más menguante petróleo venezolano está
empezando a recurrir a trucos y técnicas
propias de los contrabandistas de las películas
de Hollywood:
Aquí un ejemplo.
(Fijaos, como los petroleros venezolanos tienen
riesgo de ser confiscados… para saldar las
deudas pendientes con el petróleo que transportan…
PDVSA ha empezado a transferir en alta mar
el petróleo desde sus barcos a otros barcos
con bandera cubana… que luego se encargan
de llevar el crudo a su destino, evitando
así que sea embargado.)
Y es que amigos, en Venezuela prácticamente
todo lo que tiene valor, ha sido o está siendo
saqueado. La corrupción ha llegado a casi
todos los rincones del país.
Vamos a ver, la revolución bolivariana prometió
prosperidad…lo que se olvidaron de matizar
es que toda esa prosperidad iba a ser solo
para unos pocos… para los amigos de la revolución,
claro.
¿No me creéis?
Pues fijaos…
(Muchos miembros del régimen han promovido
y lideran el contrabando con gasolina para
venderla en Brasil y Colombia.
Son los máximos responsables del contrabando
con alimentos y medicinas comprados por el
estado y vendidos luego en el mercado negro.
Han saqueado las cuentas públicas y han desaparecido
decenas de miles de millones de dólares tanto
del gobierno como de PDVSA.)
Bueno… es que en Venezuela se han saqueado
incluso los dólares del Banco Central…
Si, tal cual como lo escucháis.
Veréis, me explico. Una de las primeras cosas
que hizo el régimen chavista fue implantar
un rígido control de cambios… que fijaba
por ejemplo, un cambio oficial entre el bolívar
y el dólar estadounidense, un tipo de cambio
que no tenía nada que ver con la cotización
en la calle.
De esta forma los amiguetes del gobierno
han podido acceder a dólares estadounidenses
entregando apenas un puñado de bolívares.
(El chollo era tal que se se estima que el
20% de todas las importaciones declaradas
eran operaciones completamente falsas que
se realizaban con el único propósito de
que conseguir dólares al cambio oficial,
dólares que luego se guardaban en cuentas
en el extranjero.
Y, ojo, porque según las estimaciones podemos
estar hablando de un robo de más de 100.000
millones de dólares.
Y por supuesto, PDVSA no se ha librado de
este expolio:
(“Un grupo de empresas prestaron a PDVSA
7.200 millones de bolívares, que, cambiados
al precio del mercado negro serían el equivalente
a casi 42 millones de dólares. Pero al ser
cambiados a tasa oficial, eso se convirtió
en aproximadamente 600 millones de dólares
que fueron depositados en una cuenta en Malta”.
César Batiz, periodista venezolano)
Pero claro… como el país ya no da más
de sí, los gerifaltes del régimen se han
buscado una nueva fuente de ingresos.
(LA CONVERSIÓN EN UN NARCOESTADO)
El tema de los narcos y Venezuela no es algo
nuevo… lo que ocurre es que, por así decirlo
ha evolucionado.
Veréis, me explico… durante muchos años,
los carteles colombianos trataron de utilizar
rutas a través de Venezuela para distribuir
sus productos.
Y, claro, para lograrlo, pues digamos que
empezaron a sobornar a policías, a miembros
de la guardia nacional, a altos funcionarios,
etcétera, etcétera. Para que hicieran la
vista gorda. Esta fue la primera etapa.
Cómo la cosa funcionaba, los narcos conocían
cada vez mejor el terreno y de quien podían
o no podían fiarse, pues se pasó a una segunda
etapa… algo así como oye, ya puestos, si
te doy más dinero, ya no solo miras para
otro lado, también proteges y te encargas
de transportar mi mercancía.Esta fue la segunda
etapa.
(Luego, muchos mafiosos colombianos se dieron
cuenta que ante la enorme presión que tenían
del gobierno colombiano y de la DEA,estarían
más seguros en Venezuela.
Así que a partir de principios del s.XXI,
eso es precisamente lo que pasó, que muchos
de estos siniestros “comerciantes" trasladaron
su centro de operaciones desde Colombia a
Venezuela. Y ahí ya la colaboración con
las autoridades empezó a ser muy, pero que
muy estrecha. )
Creo que decir estrecha es quedarse cortos
¿Qué pensáis que hizo entonces el gobierno
de Venezuela? Pues decidió, ni más ni menos,
en 2005 expulsar del territorio venezolano
a la DEA y, además, suspender el acuerdo
para monitorear los narcovuelos.
De esta forma el territorio venezolano se
convirtió en una especie de refugio para
los narcos, los Estados Unidos ya no podían
seguirles la pista.
Qué fantástico ¿no? A cambio eso sí, tenían
que pagar una modesta comisión [de algo tendrían
que vivir los gerifaltes del régimen, ¿no?]
Esta fue la tercera etapa.
Pero… esperad un momento amigos, porque
así es como llegamos a la cuarta y última
etapa que es en la que nos encontramos ahora
mismo.
(El negocio iba viento en popa… tan bien
que muchos de los gerifaltes de la revolución
bolivariana se hicieron una pregunta… Tenemos
al gobierno, a la policía, al ejercito y
un montón de recursos… ¿por qué diantres
tenemos que compartir nada con los colombianos
o con quien sea?)
¿Sabéis qué pasó entonces? Pues… Que
las autoridades venezolanas empezaron a detener
a todos los narcos que no querían cooperar
entregándoles sus rutas y su negocio de distribución…
(Así es como cayeron personajes de la talla
de Maximiliano Bonilla, alias “valenciano”
jefe de la Oficina de Envigado; Hector Germán
Buitrago, alias “Martin Llanos”; Diego
Perez Henao, alias Diego Rastrojo o Daniel
Barrera Barrera, alias “el loco”.Todos
ellos con sitio propio en la lista de los
traficantes más importantes.)
De esta forma, todo apunta a que ahora mismo
en Venezuela, aunque existen un montón de
grupos operando en el terreno [los colectivos,
los pranes, los paramilitares, el ELN, los
disidentes de las Farc, las megabandas]...…
en última instancia el control lo tienen
los gerifaltes del gobierno…
Personajes como Diosdado Cabello, presuntamente
el jefe más importante del “Cartel de los
Soles” que es como se conoce al cártel
formado por los altos mandos del gobierno bolivariano.
De hecho uno de los asistentes personales
del mismísimo Diosdado Cabello, Leasmy Salazar,
huyo de Venezuela en 2014 con ayuda de la
DEA.
Y su declaración no pudo ser más contundente:
además de aportar evidencias sobre el funcionamiento
de la organización, declaró que el señor
Diosdado Cabello, presidente de la Asamblea
Nacional Constituyente, da directamente órdenes
sobre las rutas y la salida de lanchas cargadas
con sustancias prohibidas.
Y no es el único. Los testimonios se acumulan
en los despachos de la DEA.
Ahí está, por ejemplo, la declaración de
Walid Makled cuando fue detenido en Colombia en 2011.
Makled fue uno de los narcos más
importantes de Venezuela. Controlaba por ejemplo,
Puerto Cabello, que según la DEA era la puerta
de salida para la mayor parte de los narcótico
distribuidos desde este país. Pues bien,
atentos.
(Tras su detención makled declaró con todo
lujo de detalles que tenía a sueldo a varias
decenas de generales venezolanos, así como
a altos funcionarios del gobierno, como por
ejemplo, Henry Rangel Silva… que mas tarde
fue nombrado ministro de defensa…
o a Hugo Carvajal, ex director de inteligencia del
ejercito al que supuestamente le pagaba 50.000$
semanales… ¡Menudo pedazo de suelo! También
declaró haber financiado una de las campañas
de Hugo Chavez a cambio de concesiones en
Puerto Cabello.
Con todas estas relaciones es facil entender
como en Noviembre de 2016, Efraín Antonio
Campo Flores y Francisco Flores de Freitas,
2 sobrinos de la misma Cilia Flores, la esposa
de Maduro, la primera dama venezolana fueran
condenados en un tribunal de Nueva York por
conspirar para traficar con cientos de kilos
de narcóticos.
Y es que, amigos, según las estimaciones
existentes, el negocio en Venezuela no para
de crecer… A través de este país pasa
ya entre el 15 y el 20% de toda la coca que
se mueve en el mundo cada año. Y no solo
eso, al parecer el número de laboratorios
se está multiplicando como la espuma.
(Claro… por un lado los gerifaltes de la
revolución bolivariana necesitan dinero para
mantener leales a las estructuras de represión:
al ejército, a la policía a la guardia nacional…
además a cambio de poder trabajar en Venezuela
las bandas, los colectivos, los grupos mafiosos
y hasta el ELN le brindan su apoyo al régimen…)
[Y por supuesto como el negocio es redondo,
Maduro y compañía se siguen llenando los
bolsillo.]
Desgraciadamente, las consecuencias de todo
esto son terribles:
Por un lado el saqueo de todos los recursos
públicos… ha llevado al país a la ruina;
por otro lado está alimentando una enorme
violencia…
Según datos del Observatorio Venezolano de
Violencia… en 2017… en este país hubo
89 homicidios por cada 100.000 habitantes.
Es decir, más de 26.000 personas perdieron
la vida de forma violenta.
Venezuela se ha convertido en el país más
peligroso de toda América Latina… y la
situación en algunas zonas como Caracas es
aún peor. La tasa de homicidios en la capital
se disparó en 2017 a 130 personas por cada
100.000 habitantes.
Mientras tanto los miembros del gobierno que
se están aprovechando de esta situación
y están haciendo auténticas fortunas están
comprando propiedades por todo el mundo…
desde la República Dominicana, donde están
promoviendo inversiones millonarios en hoteles,
urbanizaciones, campos de golf… hasta Madrid,
una ciudad a la que están llegando no solo
miles de venezolanos que huyen del desastre
sino también muchos familiares de todos estos
capos del “Cartel de los Soles” o de altos
cargos leales a la revolución.
(“Ahora me encuentro a veces sentado en
restaurantes de Madrid justo al lado de personas
con las que no estaría cómodo ni siquiera
viéndolas en Caracas” - Leopoldo López Gil,
padre de Leopoldo López, opositor venezolano
bajo arresto domiciliario en Caracas.)
Desgraciadamente, amigos, el régimen bolivariano…
ha encontrado en el narco… a su mejor aliado…
tanto para llenarse el bolsillo como para
mantenerse el poder.
En fin amigos, así está las cosas. Si os
ha resultado interesante el vídeo no olvideis
darle a like y suscriros al canal.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.